We had a question that Kevin said, how much exercise is sufficient to maintain a healthy
heart and cardio system without starving the body of oxygen and feeding the cancer?
Um, great question.
So it's going to that, the answer to that is going to be different for everybody to help
maintain proper metabolism of all yourselves exercise is super important.
So you have to be moving, you have to be burning glucose through your muscles.
So you don't have this excess glucose, just feeding the cancer.
Um, and then the second question was, if I feel slightly winded, is that too much?
No, I'd say that you're right at probably the right point.
You want to feel slightly winded.
You don't want to be so exhausted that you're, you're wasted and you don't want to go, okay,
you know, you're going to start working out so that you, you work out so hard because
you remember how you used to run 10 miles a day in college and you start working out so
hard that you produce so much lactic acid that you can't even get out of bed tomorrow morning.
You, you overdid it.
So you've got to go slow.
We don't want to produce all this lactic acid because that could end up being a feeder for
the cancer.
So you, okay, I haven't worked out for, I don't know how many years.
Well, get up and just start doing just a walk and then maybe only a block.
Then maybe you're going to go two blocks and you're going to go three blocks and whatever
you're going to do and you're going to lift some weights.
You want to use your muscles.
That's the key.
It doesn't have to be eating a treadmill and going for a long walk.
You could just do some calisthenics for two minutes.
That would be a great start right there.
I'm going to do some leg razors.
I'm going to stand, put my hands against the kitchen counter and I'm going to do side razors
of my legs.
10 on this side, 10 on that side and then I'm going to do, you know, 10 squats and I'm going
to do 10 jumpy jacks and that's all I'm going to start with and I was a little tired after
that because I'm really out of shape.
That's okay.
So maybe tomorrow you're going to do 10 and then by next week, you'll be up to 15.
So you want to be a little bit winded but you don't want to be exhausted.
You don't want to be producing a whole bunch of lactic acid.
The longer the more you do it on a regular basis, you're going to be able to do a lot more
exercise and get much more benefit, much more call to energy to the muscles.
The muscles burning glucose so that there's less glucose circulated for your cancer and
you're not producing a lot of lactic acid.
Good question.